se sabe de la salud de los presos
políticos y de las condiciones en la
cárcel policial de el chipote donde hay
denuncias de reducción de los alimentos
a niveles inhumanos
sin claramente la denuncia son reiterada
de malos tratos que podrían constituir
tortura están aislados con visitas
completamente irregulares y claramente
pues hemos podido observar el mundo
entero esta exposición deshumanizante no
una exposición deshumanizante porque no
es voluntaria y porque también luego los
medios de comunicación oficialistas han
utilizado estas imágenes para seguir
denigrando y estigmatizando a las
personas que están detenidas de forma
arbitraria solo por ejercer su derecho
solo por alzar su voz no entonces
seguimos observando este uso indebido
también del derecho penal este uso del
sistema judicial como una de las
herramientas favoritas del gobierno de
adén ortega para seguir y perpetuar la
represión ahora se están emprendiendo o
se pueden emprender alguna acción legal
para protegerlos
bueno lamentablemente como decía hemos
visto desde el inicio la crisis de
derechos humanos de forma clara y
evidente y lohan también documentados
mecanismos internacionales de derechos
humanos como el sistema funciona está
completamente
desprovisto de su independencia no y es
utilizado en nuestra estrategia
represora del gobierno actual
a propósito de estas audiencias
que se llamaron informativas por parte
del gobierno y
organizaciones locales denunciaron que
claramente esta figura legal ni siquiera
está regulada en este la normativa penal
nicaragüense y que por lo tanto fue
utilizado como un pretexto no un
pretexto para hacer
ciertamente esta exposición
deshumanizante con lo cual
lamentablemente este no esperamos que
del sistema judicial nicaragüense
resulte en ningún proceso que respete
este la debida garantía no y ahí es la
importancia desde la comunidad
internacional de continuar alzando su
voz continuar acompañando a las víctimas
y continuar con el escrutinio
internacional y con todas las
herramientas diplomáticas que tiene a su
disposición
para que el gobierno nicaragüense de una
vez por todas cumpla con sus
obligaciones internacionales
señora valencia y en qué van los
procesos judiciales de los detenidos y
que se puede esperar al respecto
bueno las organizaciones locales que
denuncian ciertamente del inicio de los
procesos judiciales pues están plagados
de irregularidades
y ciertamente esta audiencia informativa
fue una prueba de cómo en nicaragua el
sistema judicial es utilizado al antojo
del gobierno para reprimir para
amedrentarnos entonces lamentablemente
pues es un sistema judicial que es
incapaz completamente de respetar este
los derechos de los detenidos con lo
cual pues el escenario futuro en el
escenario venidero es desolador no
ciertamente y por eso es que es tan
vital el papel de la comunidad
internacional y ese escrutinio
indispensable y necesario que no debe
detenerse